wir schauen hier in die ukraine der ort
solle da im osten des landes war einst
berühmt für seine salzbergwerke jetzt
liegt er im kessel der russischen
invasoren die kämpfe dauern an die angst
der ukraine dass sich dieser kessel
schließt bild-reporter bian stritzel
wein solle dann besuchte dort die
menschen die dort noch ausharren
östlich von pharma tors sind die
ukrainischen soldaten schwer unter
beschuss bild im umkämpften kessel in
der nähe schweres artilleriefeuer wir
sind hier im donbass umkämpften kessel
die ukrainischen verteidiger haben wir
einen schweren stand hinter mir liegt
die man diese stadt kleinstadt die bis
vor kurzem noch gehalten wurde sieht
jetzt danach aus dass die russischen
invasion hier einen großteil der stadt
erobert haben die große sorge der
ukraine das ist den russen gelingt den
kessel zu schließen und die ukrainische
nein halten es geht in den kleinen ort
solle da überall zerstörungen
wir treffen nina sie nimmt uns mit zu
ihrem haus dort ist auch nadeshda die
beiden frauen zeigen uns den keller dort
in der dunkelheit sitzt eine dritte frau
hier schlafen sie
dann bietet die alte frau den reportern
eier an
nina ist nicht nach lachen zumute sie
ist erschüttert
[Musik]
erschüttert im gezeichnet vom kick
es geht in die wohnung sie ist
verbarrikadiert
die frau zeigt uns noch kurz die gegend
dann geht es weiter
es geht in den norden nach nikolai lief
wieder heftige kämpfe auch hier raub und
explosionen der krieg allgegenwärtig
die bange frage
können die russen den kessel schließen
[Musik]
und direkt in die ukraine zu unserem
reporter wie ein stritzel in nie
probieren dass die menschen dort im
donbass besucht die sich in den kellern
aufhalten du hast mit nina gesprochen
schilder und zu einmal was der krieg mit
ihren ihnen macht so lange leben sie
schon in dieser situation und die lage
dort im don was spitzt sich für sie dazu
also dort dann in dieser kleinstadt
deswegen gesehen haben solide an diesen
dieser ist als mina dort dort ist es
natürlich besonders
besonders schwierig für die menschen das
leben jetzt dort in kellern in den
letzten wochen war der russische
artilleriebeschuss noch mal besonders
zugenommen hat die stadt liegt an einer
strategisch wichtigen fernstraßen wir
waren vor zwei tagen auch noch sind dann
wieder umgekehrt
unsere beschuss auf dieser straße zu
schwer war gestern hat die russische
armee dann diese straße bereits auch
eingenommen das heißt sie stehen jetzt
unbedingt noch vor dieser kleinen stadt
und das leben für die menschen dort kann
man sich natürlich entsprechend
vorstellen es leben dort ohne strom ohne
wasser waren dort im keller aus mit
wenigen vorlegen die sie noch haben
und wissen im prinzip nicht wie es wie
es weitergeht wenn dieser kessel
geschlossen werden soll und bieten dir
dann das fand ich eine sehr berührende
szene noch ihre vorräte an sind dann
noch bereit zu teilen und ihr essen
abzugeben obwohl dort die lage total
aussichtslos ist wie ist die situation
dort wie ihr geht diese einkesselung
voran denn man hat den eindruck dass
sich dieser kessel derzeit immer enger
zieht
genau also das sind in so einer
zangenbewegung es gibt quasi mehrere
optionen die russische
option juristisch haben wir
offensichtlich ins visier genommen hat
zum einen kleineren kessel etwas weiter
nordöstlich dann einen größeren kessel
der auch so funktioniert da als auch die
etwas weiter südlich gelegene stadt
mahmud umfasst und in diesen in diesem
kessel bei ihm schwer abzusehen ist wann
sich sozusagen diese zahl schließt das
strömen dann immer noch flüchtlinge aus
diesen dörfern heraus versuchen sich
dann sozusagen aus einem perspektivisch
schließen den kessel heraus zu retten
allerdings ist das natürlich muss eine
abwägungssache viele haben nicht die
finanziellen ressourcen sich irgendwo
anders kann irgendwo anders
runterzukommen und da vielleicht über
wochen monate oder vielleicht auch ja
vielleicht auch für immer dort zu
bleiben sondern gar schon
ja ihr haus ihr ganzes leben und gehabt
und das fällt vielen hat sehr schwer
wird sich dort sich zurückzuziehen und
viele haben darauf pochen darauf dass
die russische armee noch
zurückgeschlagen werden kann rechtzeitig
eine ausweglose situation für viele
menschen die dort leben du hast auch den
ukrainischen soldaten ins gesicht
schauen können wir weiterhin verzweifelt
versuchen stand zu halten die russischen
invasoren zurückzuschlagen in dieser
einkesselung ist-situation was konntest
du in ihren gesichtern ablesen
in mehreren fällen war es so dass wir
zurückkehren also daran gesehen haben
die aus diesem kessel zurückgeschlagen
wurden die eine frage stellen mussten
die die sich dort zurückziehen mussten
da konnte man in den gesichtern dieser
zurückziehen ukrainische soldaten schon
deutlich sehen dass
sie sehr abgekämpft aus sehr sehr
mitgenommen von den kämpfen da war
eine große eine große frustration zu
spüren um das mal vorsichtig zu
formulieren
stritzel uns zugeschaltet aus die pro
vielen herzlichen dank für deine
information